[Music]
the heart center at Nationwide
Children's is dedicated to the unique
needs of patients with hypoplastic left
heart syndrome and other forms of single
ventricle heart defects
the heart is an efficient muscular pump
a normal heart is composed of four
chambers the right atrium right
ventricle left atrium and left ventricle
deoxygenated blood shown as blue returns
from the body into the right atrium next
blood moves into the right ventricle
which pumps it through the pulmonary
artery to the lungs to be oxygenated
from the lungs oxygenated blood shown as
red returns to the heart into the left
atrium through four pulmonary veins it
then enters the left ventricle which
pumps blood through the aorta to the
rest of the body in the womb the fetus
receives oxygen from the placenta so
blood can bypass the lungs blood
bypasses the lungs in two ways one way
is through an opening in the wall
between the right and left atria called
the foramen ovale the other way is
through a connection between the aorta
and pulmonary artery called the ductus
arteriosus normally these openings close
a day or two after birth because
increased blood pressure in the left
atrium causes the foramen ovale to close
and the presence of oxygen causes the
ductus arteriosus to close
hypoplastic left heart syndrome occurs
when the left side of the heart does not
form normally the result is that the
structures of the left side of the heart
including the aorta aortic valve left
ventricle mitral valve and left atrium
are very small or hypoplastic as a
result the left side of the heart can't
pump blood to the body properly
however oxygen-rich blood returning from
the lungs can bypass the hypoplastic
left heart by passing through the
foramen ovale which has remained open
into the right atrium there oxygen-rich
blood mixes with oxygen-poor blood
returning from the body then the blood
passes to the right ventricle and is
pumped through the pulmonary artery to
the lungs as well as across the still
open ductus arteriosus to the body if a
hypoplastic left heart is left untreated
the foramen ovale or ductus arteriosus
or both will close as they normally do
after birth as a result blood flow to
the body is not only low but is also
oxygen poor endangering the baby's life
a series of operations as well as
medications are necessary to save the
baby's life the operations include the
hybrid stage one comprehensive stage two
and fontan completion all of which are
shown in their entirety in other videos
our single ventricle team at Nationwide
Children's is dedicated to supporting
your child we are available to answer
all of your questions at any time at six
one four seven two two two five three
zero and at Nationwide Children's org
slash heart